hello and welcome to this video playing
pool and be I'll crush on me something
like that to see specify our quad army
okay he's an IM but I don't know this
person so I went for you for trying to
get more variety in the openings yeah I
don't really like the open society in
that match against 96 the specially
cough yeah let's just play the Russell
emo variation a d6 is an interesting way
to play now but you don't see that as so
often d 6 + g six combined yeah it feels
like I just get a good Center surprised
by this opening play yeah white should
be better him with the with the central
um central control anyway what to do
here I don't think well I can go d5 this
is not this is this is easy let's say
let's play this is of an easy
continuation if he goes back to be eight
it looks kind of wrong even though it
might not be a bad move what
why would you want to go to a five of
all squares okay I cannot go before
immediately that's kind of clear because
of the long diagonal yeah I wonder if i
take my tick with the night then it will
be difficult to I think I want to keep
this keep this piece on the board yeah I
expect Bishop g4 now so that you can't
read at least one minor piece no okay I
give up he never plays a move that I
expect yeah I should know ok I think h3
is ok Bishop g4 is good to prevent was
thinking maybe Queenie to the thought he
had maybe Nyjah form but as I said he
never plays a look that I vaguely expect
hmm
yeah maybe has to try some queen bee 62
before some some kind of plan like that
yeah that's also interesting try to get
be five and nine c4n
a four he's got a night be three so this
is not not a good idea yep okay to watch
I use them more time he probably managed
be five in 94
maybe I could have prevented this
somehow it I didn't see how okay so
wants to use the c-4 scram we are 94
Bishop c4 I guess yeah I think and put
the bishop here okay no I didn't see
that move that's bad pretty sure if
considered 96
hmm now I didn't I didn't play that well
that opening with Knight a5 certainly
could have been exploited a lot better
now i have basically nothing I'm not
sure maybe I maybe it's still equal but
it might be that black is better it's
very much possible camp let's go for
that pin now d for I have to retreat
unfortunately but well II five is also
move but probably not that great I just
wanted to retreat him for night BTW to
next
yeah let's so let's play along probably
oops nope matt BTW too yeah i'm curious
to check out to it his opening play with
them with 95 was was pretty terrible but
he played well afterwards oh i play
badly or both it's a some combination
well I mean I don't think I'm in
terrible shape here but it's not what um
yeah what should have happened let's say
nine age five maybe no wow very forceful
play ok I can take do for but it's not
so great yeah I think I probably have to
take here and take this
ya know immediately grabs here okay okay
it's difficult cannot go pee should be
five unfortunately I can take and play
hooky three I guess yeah tilhar the same
not sure about this 93 will create stuff
Oh goes f5 Wow yeah why not time morning
why not indeed
g4s f1 now that's the idea I guess ok
I don't really want to take on e4 I just
not c4 I was thinking possibly f3 at
some moment okay I can shake a call so
first I yes got Queenie for at the end
well Jack still have to do that I guess
guys got t3 coming very uncomfortable
check
yeah it's totally lost of course I can
probably win this on time there are
unhurt now you might be good enough to
check me to make me check white
foreheads on time yeah whatever or
whatever yeah that it was saw was a
really tough Jam so how could I have won
this game out of the opening and
probably it's probably possible or let
least show some kind of big edge should
be possible because this is just
terrible but that that kind of plane but
afterwards he played extremely well not
night c4 which I felt was kind of can
almost mandatory but yeah this is ok
it's really ok from Jeff may its and so
bad
95 just looks like total nonsense
regardless but it seems that i don't i
don't get to play before and sideline
the piece yeah maybe h3 is too slow as
possible maybe that's sooo slow the the
computer gives vertically advantage but
it wants to play with this and here in
22 and we'll see one end to be three if
I can prevent him from from getting ever
to c4 or kind of get this back into the
game then I'm really better but seems to
be difficult to do so yeah maybe it
wasn't so bad pretty bad to me yeah I
know okay this is this is just a
terrible movement I just didn't see
knight c6 at all losing time yeah i know
i'm not quite sure i don't think that i
should be should be in such terrible
shape here but this is just very
powerfully played yeah i have five is a
good move Quincy six is very strong and
check Joe
very uncomfortable position a very
uncomfortable position hard to save I
can hold the engine wants to play we
should be six now this chain this is
this is losing will be 183 was even
check more decisive yeah also I didn't
see anything against they have it I
could I couldn't figure out and move
here just a bad position yeah bishop d6
okay he doesn't have a clear check reply
to that here I've got kinda a five from
probably going for some kind of counter
check check check and I get this porn
that's the thing wow I have very tough
to play yeah it seems that I didn't
evaluate the position correctly 95 I
really thought that this is total
nonsense but it's not so bad I mean
white can can get an advantage but it's
not as clear as a thought and I probably
have to avoid the age 3 move I was
thinking he would probably play Bishop
g4 happy to trade some peace as he's got
less less space but he never did that it
might be might be a lot of time yet the
bishop is probably better here so that
is like not c4 is not coming with some
kind of tempo it could be five Luke see
one this is only only a slight edge for
white it's only a slight edge for wide
yeah I guess a very strong game by my
opponent in this was really bad my
plaque is ok here yeah the night on a
five that looks sidelined no hazard has
a clear purpose ok thanks for watching